bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal de
la rédaction au sommaire ce soir nous
parlerons de ces communautés religieuses
rassemblées ce jeudi soir à Plaisir
notamment pour rendre hommage aux
victimes de Charlie Hebdo et puis il
s'inquiète du devenir des mineurs
étrangers isolés une nouvelle
disposition du conseil général ne
convainc pas les associations solidaires
et bien nous entendrons dans quelques
instants audil Jouanne de Réseau
éducation sans frontières qui est avec
moi en plateau bonjour bonsoir à vous
catholique juif musulman ensemble à
plaisir pour dénoncer la barbarie de
l'attaque contre la rédaction de Charlie
Hebdo c'était un plaisir hier soir les
commutateurs religieuses qui veulent
maintenant éviter les amalgames Mélanie
pocket
des bougies des pancartes et toujours
cette phrase devenue un symbole je suis
Charlie 400 plaisirs rois étaient réunis
hier soir en solidarité avec les
victimes de la fusillade parmi eux des
représentants de trois communautés
religieuses
en tant que citoyen c'est une valeur
fondamentale de vivre le respect mutuel
la liberté de conscience
nous condoléances sont vers toutes
les familles qui sont mises à l'épreuve
rue du monde avec aussi cette espérance
religieuse que nous sommes fait pour la
vie nous sommes faits pour l'unité nous
sommes faits pour vivre ensemble et que
si justement nous sommes tous différents
c'est parce que et bien quelque part
pour nous croyants quelqu'un l'a voulu
que nous soyons tous différents non pas
pour nous battre mais pour au contraire
nous enrichir mutuellement je pense que
d'abord en tant que citoyen c'est très
important c'est pour
venir dire à tout le monde que
toute personne douille d'intelligence et
de raison ne peut pas accepter un tel
acte c'est inacceptable et en tant que
musulman nous va leur nous verser
coranique ne le rappelle nous le disent
clairement sans aucune
que celui qui tue une âme c'est comme
c'est là-dessus de l'humanité entière
une bonne rôle réalisée par des jeunes
des applaudissements une minute de
silence et la Marseillaise un moment
important pour le maire qui a côtoyé de
journalistes dessinateurs
simples simples mais d'une simplicité
impressionnante et avec une vraie
profondeur culturelle et une vraie
analyse analyse analyse je dirais de
culturel mais en plus
une humanité incroyable avec un regard
sain d'autres manifestations sont
prévues ce week-end le prochain numéro
de Charlie Hebdo sortira mercredi 14
janvier il est actuellement réalisé dans
les locaux du journal Libération pour
que la flamme de la liberté d'expression
ne s'éteignent pas
on passe maintenant l'entretien de ce
journal bonjour au 10 juin vous êtes
membre du groupe jeune de RESF sans
frontières RSF 78 pardon Réseau
éducation sans frontières d'abord je
voudrais un
réaction sur ces événements tragiques
survenir chez les Hebdo parce que sur
les Hebdo était un des soutiens les plus
forts de RESF parmi les journalistes oui
pendant quatre ans toutes les semaines
il y avait une rubrique de SF dans le
journal papier de Charlie Hebdo qui
malheureusement à l'époque était rempli
toutes les semaines par une expulsion
d'un jeune ou d'un père ou d'une mère ou
d'une famille entière d'enfance
scolarisées il y avait un engagement
aussi à travers certains livres qui ont
été réalisés au profit de RSF avec des
avec des caricatures dedans des
dessinateurs aujourd'hui décédés alors
justement il s'agit donc au bout de
trois ans de ces rubriques hebdomadaires
d'uniquement plus une publication dans
le livre de toutes ces rubriques et
chaque page a été
bénévolement gratuitement au bénéfice de
l'essf fait par des différents
dessinateurs dont malheureusement
beaucoup ont été décédés maintenant ou
même blessés dont charpe et beaucoup
d'autres et ça c'est des ouvrages qu'on
peut retrouver en qui sont épuisés
depuis longtemps mais c'était le clin
d'oeil évidemment que vous vouliez
donner à cet événement vous êtes en
plateau avec nous on va maintenant
parler de ce qui nous interpelle
aujourd'hui le 28 novembre 2012 il y a
eu la mise en place de la circulaire
valse sur la régularisation des jeunes
majeurs alors pour obtenir des papiers
il faut dorénavant qu'il soit arrivé en
France avant 16 ans qu'il vivent avec
leurs parents or la plupart de ces
jeunes ne sont pas dans cette situation
donc ils peuvent pas obtenir qu'un titre
de séjour étudiants et une fois les
études terminées mais ils doivent
repartir et c'est ce qui vous inquiète
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que la plupart
des jeunes étrangers qui arrivent en
France sont aujourd'hui condamnés à
vivre sans papiers c'est ça non ils ont
pas condamnés à vivre sans papiers
heureusement c'est un peu fort peut-être
disons que ils ont un parcours difficile
donc là vous venez de parler des jeunes
qui sont en famille donc effectivement
et puis on peut aussi parler maintenant
parce pense que depuis un an leur SF a
été amené à soutenir beaucoup de jeunes
isolés donc ils n'ont pas de famille en
France alors quelle est la situation
pour eux alors justement jusqu'en 2013
leur situation est en France était
relativement correct ils étaient
accueillis comme ils devaient l'être
dans le respect des lois et leur
réalisation et donc été faite
pratiquement automatiquement dans le
cadre des lois aussi et là à partir de
2013 ça a changé depuis 2013 on est
j'allais dire presque harcelés par les
éducateurs qui sont en angoisse complète
face à l'avenir des jeunes dont ils
s'occupent des fois depuis deux trois
quatre ans et qui voit disparaître
effectivement
alors le set février prochain vous le
groupe des jeunes de RSF 78 organisent
justement des assises départementales à
Versailles ce sera donc le 7 février ce
sera l'occasion de donner la parole à
ces jeunes absolument c'est principe
d'habitude on fait des parrainages qui
sont plus des cérémonies un peu
officielles on donne la parole aux élus
et aux citoyens cette année on a décidé
de donner beaucoup plus la parole aux
jeunes donc il y aura une quinzaine de
jeunes qui vont témoigner de leur
parcours de leur histoire et de leurs
problèmes et de leur victoire c'est une
grande majorité maintenant sont
régularisés il y a une particularité
dans les Yvelines ce que vous pouvez
nous l'expliquer alors il y a deux
particularités il y en a une côté
préfecture
à propos des jeunes isolés les lois sont
relativement correctes vous parlez tout
à l'heure de la circulaire la circulaire
pour les jeunes isolés et plutôt
positive puisque elle rappelle d'abord
les lois du temps de Sarkozy ça veut
dire les lois Besson de juin 2011 et
elle
arrange encore en mieux cette loi en
disant il faut l'appliquer une manière
bienveillante soyez souple soit il est
large d'esprit et puis si une
correspondent pas à cette loi-là au
moins un titre étudiant mais de fait
c'était vraiment une bonne chose le
problème c'est que la spécificité du son
18 la préfecture n'applique pas cette
loi Besson donc et donc pas non plus la
circulaire donc là on ne demande pas le
changement on demande l'application
donc ça c'est dramatique pour eux et
l'autre particularité c'est elle vient
cette fois-ci du conseil général des
histoires absolument alors l'autre
particularité c'est que les jeunes
isolés étant mineur isolé ne peuvent
demander un titre de séjour qu'à l'heure
18 ans donc le lendemain de leur 18 ans
et comme le jour de leur 18 ans la
grande majorité sont à la rue là c'est
la politique du Conseil Général ben
c'est ce qu'on appelle le serpent qui se
met à la queue puisque on les met à la
rue à 18 ans à 18 ans plus un jour ils
ne peuvent pas être régularisés jusqu'à
présent ces jeunes isolés étaient
épaulé aidé des associations maintenant
ils le seront plus que par une seule
association
que avant et toujours maintenant
d'ailleurs les jeunes qui arrivent sur
le territoire quel que soit leur raison
leur histoire il y a du tout il y a pas
que ce qu'on voit et qu'on connaît les
Africains qui suit la guerre ou la
misère il y a des Égyptiens Coop il y a
des ordres de l'Est il y en a qui
viennent de tous les pays pour des
raisons complètement différentes c'est
pas que fuir la misère et la guerre des
fois c'est un projet personnel parce que
les parents s'entendent pas comme
n'importe quel français ils quitte le
domicile et ils vont ailleurs quoi donc
tous ces jeunes là sont considérés dans
la loi française et dans le loi
international comme des jeunes en danger
et donc par un jugement donc ça devient
vraiment de l'égalité sont placés à
l'aide sociale à l'enfance en France en
danger comme n'importe quel français qui
aurait des problèmes ou d'orphelins bien
sûr mais même qui serait qui serait
victime de violence de sa famille par
exemple
et cette azote donc aide sociale à
l'enfant c'est le conseil général un
financièrement et qui dirige cette chose
là et le Conseil général n'a pas de
foyer en tant que tel et donc il confie
à des associations
non pas du tout pas du tout il fait une
station qui gère des foyers
ou autre des relations qui ont une
expérience et qui accueille donc aussi
ces jeunes Français isolés ou enlever
leur famille ou protéger de leur famille
et donc ils ont une grande expérience
d'accueillir des jeunes en danger et
donc dans chaque foyer il y a deux trois
quatre cinq étrangers parmi des dizaines
de Français avec des éducateurs
expérimentés dans le travail et donc à
ce moment-là nous effectivement on était
pas sollicité d'accord mais qu'est-ce
qui a changé donc
d'abord depuis un an les jeunes
étrangers ne sont plus envoyés en foyer
avec leur les jeunes Français mais sont
discriminés ils envoyé en hôtel
complètement isolé donc depuis un an ils
sont notamment un suivi social il y a
sûrement pas un suivi il y a même un
blocage quand eux veulent être
scolariser ou faire autre chose pour
s'intégrer en France donc ça c'était une
première chose depuis un an ou deux et
puis alors là récemment donc du mois
d'octobre
ils ont ils confient tous ces jeunes à
une seule association donc le lien
yvelinois qui n'a aucune expérience
de l'encadrement de ces jeunes puisque
c'est ce que vous avez peur c'est que
ces jeunes évidemment c'est un peu à
eux-mêmes alors c'est pas qu'on a peur
parce que le lien est Vinois on a disons
des bons retours au niveau de leur
travail sur
leur profession ça veut dire le logement
ils se sont ça fait 6 mois qui se
prépare ils ont embauché ils ont formé
donc on va pas avant le début de
l'extravail dire ils vont me le faire
par contre ce qu'on regrette c'est que
la discrimination qui commençait là est
officielle puisque non seulement ils
vont mettre tous ceux qui s'étaient en
hôtel donc pourquoi pas discriminer
isolé discriminer par le avec le lien
Vinois ça peut être aussi bien au même
mieux mais là ils veulent enlever des
foyers tous les jeunes étrangers
uniquement parce qu'ils sont étrangers
et ce qui s'est passé au mois de
décembre c'est que les foyers donc il y
a une cinquantaine de foyers j'ai pas un
ou deux ont reçu un courrier
donc du conseil général donnant la liste
des jeunes qui devaient les quitter dans
la semaine sans savoir où ils allaient
c'est brutale c'est plus que brutal pour
les jeunes et ça a pris complet pour les
travailleurs sociaux qui travaillaient
depuis des années à suivre ces jeunes
d'accord donc une mobilisation de un
appel au secours des éducateurs qui ne
peuvent pas dire ce qu'ils veulent parce
que ils sont salariés et subventionnés
par le Conseil Général et qui ont
demandé à westf d’être un haut-parleur
nous on ne fait rien de dans ce
travail-là on ne fait que le
haut-parleur vous êtes le porte-parole
de la problématique et donc à l'occasion
de ces assises départementales qui ont
lieu le 7 février ce sera évidemment
l'occasion d'entendre c'est ces jeunes
oui mais enfin disons que les assis
c'est beaucoup plus général que ça sera
aussi une façon de se mobiliser
absolument merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur le plateau du journal pour nous
expliquer les problématiques que vous
encore rencontre notamment RESF autour
de ces mineurs isolés merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup on change tout à fait de
sujets à travers des s de magie dans les
hôpitaux des bénévoles de l'association
les magiciens du cœur tentent de sortir
les enfants malades de leur quotidien
reportage au sein du centre hospitalier
de Versailles
au service de pédiatrie du centre
hospitalier de Versailles de niveau Var
déambule dans les couloirs avec tout son
équipement de magie et pousse la porte
de chaque chambre
et là tu sens un petit picotement
bénévole et président de l'association
les magiciens du coeur il vient ici
toutes les semaines à la rencontre des
enfants malades pour les sortir un peu
de leur quotidien quand on fait de la
magie on arrive à étonner à étonné son
spectateur et quand on l’étonne il y a
plein de résistance qui tombent et tout
de suite on est sur une relation avec
beaucoup moins de barrières une relation
beaucoup plus vraie
Minata commence à bien le connaître et
est l'une de ses premières fans
chaque fois que je le vois et ben j'aime
bien c'est tout c'est drôle et puis
aussi l'effort je pense qu'il devrait
monter un spectacle et engagé des gens
curieuse elle lui a déjà demandé ses
petits secrets mais sans succès il a dit
qu'un magicien ça révèle pas ses secrets
ce magicien grand cœur vient ici depuis
5-6 ans il est aujourd'hui reconnu par
le personnel soignant de l'hôpital
parfois même complice avec eux c'est un
travail pratiquement d'équipe j'ai
l'impression d'être intégré dans
l'équipe donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
fait vraiment plaisir
quelques mètres plus loin la petite
Roxane fait la rencontre du magicien
pour la première fois
je la mets dans ma main
je souffle sur ma main
elle a disparu mais je me demande bien
où elle est cette fleur personne n'a vu
la fleur
un peu timide au début elle esquisse
finalement quelques petits sourires
c'est très bien
parce que les journées sont parfois
longues surtout pour les petits comme ça
donc voilà un peu de un peu de spectacle
de magie ça fait toujours un bon moment
à passer pour ces petits
je suis un grand magicien
et je fais des coloriages
les magiciens du coeur seront également
dans les hôpitaux de Bullion et de
Garches et dans quelques instituts
médico-éducatifs
au grand cœur dernière partie de notre
rétrospective consacrée l'année 2014 je
vous propose maintenant de retrouver les
événements qui sont survenus au mois de
novembre et décembre dernier il sera
notamment en question du projet skidome
je l'ai à Elancourt encore du mouvement
des médecins qui a ponctué cette fin
d'année
dernier rétrospective de cette année
2014 le plan antivol à main armée a été
lancé de manière anticipée dans quatre
départements d'Île-de-France dans les
Yvelines ce plan prévoit un renforcement
des forces de l'ordre dans les centres
commerciaux les écoliers de Jean Lurçat
et Elsa Triolet à Guyancourt ont un
nouvel établissement scolaire après les
vacances de la Toussaint ils ont fait
leur rentrée dans un bâtiment HQE Haute
Qualité Environnementale il n'y aura pas
finalement de pistes de ski couvertes à
Élancourt le projet de ski de Home
défendu par l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines a été gelée en raison d'un
manque de visibilité sur le financement
du projet l'annonce a été faite début
novembre
plus de 250 élèves rassemblés pour
célébrer la commémoration de l'Armistice
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux la ville a reçu
le label décerné par l'Office national
des combattants 12 communes seulement du
département bénéficient pour le
centenaire de la grande guerre pour ces
commémorations trappes de son côté à
inaugurer une statue de Jean Jaurès mort
assassiné en juillet 1914 l'homme
politique s'était fait remarquer par son
opposition à la Première Guerre mondiale
cocorico love skull observatoire de
Versailles Saint-Quentin est parti
prenante dans l'aventure spatiale avec
la mission Rosetta le robot filae était
déployé sur la comète tchourique pour
livrer les secrets du système solaire
en ce 21 novembre nouvelle action des
avocats plus de 300 d'entre eux se sont
rassemblés devant la cour d'appel de
Versailles pour protester contre les
réformes Macron est Taubira une
manifestation qui a eu lieu alors que le
président du Conseil national des
barreaux et de la Conférence des
Bâtonniers était reçu à Matignon pour
obtenir l'arbitrage de Manuel Valls la
mobilisation c'est poursuivi pendant
tout le mois de décembre allez un
événement people Nabilla à la prison des
femmes de Versailles la starlette de
téléréalité soupçonnée d'avoir poignardé
son compagnon est incarcéré depuis le 9
novembre le 20 novembre elle s'était
rendu devant la cour d'appel de
Versailles pour demander sa remise en
liberté 30 ans que le Resto du Coeur ont
démarré leur première campagne de
solidarité 30 ans quel bilan tiré alors
que les premiers repas sont servis
depuis ce lundi 24 novembre exemple à
Rambouillet où les bénévoles accueillent
une centaine de familles
les habitants du quartier Jaurès gare de
la ville de Trappes sont inquiets un
cabinet médical serait amené à fermer et
les médecins se feraient de plus en plus
rares dans le secteur réunis au sein du
comité de quartier des trappistes ont
lancé une pétition
le maire de Coignières lance une
consultation populaire la question posée
à ses administrés souhaitez-vous ou non
un élargissement de la Communauté de
Communes des étangs à laquelle la ville
est rattachée une sorte de référendum
ensuite transmis au préfet de région
alors que ce dernier a présenté un
projet d'intercommunalité à plus de
800000 habitants à une très large
majorité et sans surprise les Coignières
ne veulent pas de se redécoupage et puis
après les urgentistes quelques jours
auparavant ce sont les médecins
généralistes et les spécialistes qui
leur emboîtent le pas pour un mouvement
de grève débuté à la veille de Noël dans
le collimateur des médecins certains
éléments du projet de loi santé de
Marisol Touraine les médecins de la
maison médicale de Montigny le
Bretonneux était mobilisé au retour des
vacances les médecins ont cessé leur
grève mais boycotent la carte vitale et
c'est sur ces dernières informations que
se referme notre rétro 2014
voilà et pour une dernière fois en cette
fin de semaine nous sommes allés vous
demander quels sont vos bonnes
résolutions pour 2015 voici vos réponses
que ça soit mieux que l'année 2014 où je
vais pas me plaindre donc voilà un peu
de vacances un peu de beau temps les
saisons rester en forme
gagnant au loto
et aider tout ce qui sont dans la rue
trouver un logement voilà prof
ITER de la si possible enfin juste des
choses positives pour mes enfants
surtout pas avoir de problèmes dans leur
travail entre autres moi j'ai pour 2015
parce que
et puis pour être plus détendu et
coule avec les autres et avec moi-même
quoi
comme la plupart des Français je me suis
dit que j'allais pas tenir de résolution
parce que c'est souvent dur de les tenir
et il se passe tellement d'imprévus dans
la vie que c'est dur de tenir comme ça
une ligne de conduite de résolution donc
je préfère pas en avoir cette année
voilà ne pas avoir de résolution c'est
peut-être la meilleure façon de la tenir
allez retour avant de se quitter sur
deux informations de cette semaine
écoulées nous apprenions lundi le décès
de Jean-Pierre Beltoise ancien pilote de
Formule 1 qui depuis sa retraite c'était
installé dans les Yvelines avec un
circuit qui porte son nom à trappe
86 Grands Prix de Formule 1 8 podiums
dont le mythique succès à Monaco en 1972
sous une pluie battante pilote à l'aise
partout 11 fois champion de France de
moto 14 participations 24 Heures du Mans
Jean-Pierre Beltoise aime la compétition
par-dessus tout et les qualités de
trajectoire Jean-Pierre a été le premier
qui a redonné un certain lustre au sport
automobile français et qui a entraîné
dans la foulée d'abord une
revalorisation du sport automobile qui
était un peu tombée en désuétude en
France et une réussite qui inspire de
nombreux pilotes comme Arnaud Jabouille
ou encore Prost après sa carrière il a
consacré la suite de sa vie à la
sécurité des pilotes développe des
stages de prévention notamment au
circuit qui portait son nom à Trappes
avec sa méthode conduire juste si vous
voulez ça m'intéresse pas du tout de
faire des circuits pour faire plaisir ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de faire des
circuits pour qu'un jour le gouvernement
et les responsables des boîtes disent
mais effectivement avec le système mis
au point par Jean-Pierre Beltoise et
conduire juste on réduit de moitié ou
des ou des deux tiers ou des trois cas
accidents de la route très proche de son
personnel ici
à Trappes parce que la plupart des gens
qui ont collaboré avec lui l'ont fait et
le fond depuis quasiment l'origine
c'est-à-dire pour la majorité de nos
collaborateurs c'est plus de 20 ans
Jean-Pierre Beltoise est décédé à l'âge
de 77 ans après deux accidents
cardiovasculaires à Dakar
et puis dans l'actualité de cette
semaine également les enseignants du
collège Philippe de Champaigne était en
grève jeudi pour protester contre la
sortie et de leur établissement scolaire
des réseaux d'éducation prioritaire les
reps ils se sont rassemblés aux
alentours de l'établissement pour
informer les habitants du ministre mais
également de la verrière puisque les
élèves de cette commune sont scolarisées
dans cet établissement Mélanie pocket
il ne décolère pas les enseignants du
collège Philippe de Champaigne n'ont pas
assuré les cours aujourd'hui trois
semaines après l'annonce de la ministre
de l'Éducation c'est l'incompréhension
qui domine on ne comprend pas d'autant
plus que
ce qui nous fait mal au cœur c'est
qu'elle est justifiée par le fait que
entre autres elle est entre autres
justifiée par le fait que nos résultats
s'améliorent et que notre collège
fonctionne la perte des moyens ça va
aider les moyens d'horaires des moyens
humains aussi ou en termes d'encadrement
principalement c'est à dire que
la peur des moyens horaires peut aussi
impacter sur les effectifs de classe
l'établissement Philippe de Champaigne
c'est 427 élèves répartis dans 17
classes les collégiens viennent
principalement de la ville du Mesnil et
de la verrière
ce journal du vendredi 9 janvier
maintenant terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi retour de l'information locale en
direct ce sera lundi à 18h j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver une dernière
pensée évidemment dans clôturer ce
journal au Proche et aux victimes des
victimes pardon de la fusillade de
Charlie Hebdo et je vous rappelle ce
rassemblement dimanche à 15h place de la
République pour défendre la liberté
d'expression je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend